his work on flow patterns and workings
of the oceans in the high latitudes and
the oceans role in climate and he's
chair of a large international program
that focuses on understanding ocean
transports of heat and freshwater in the
Arctic and subarctic oceans related to
this he's also interested in the
environmental knowledge of the North's
colonists to Iceland and Greenland in
the Middle Ages and today he'll talk to
us about Greenland Norse knowledge of
the North Atlantic environment thanks
Tom
Thank You Marylou and thank you for the
invitation to speak so my background is
in ocean circulation and dynamics I'm
trained in physics originally I have no
credentials in history or archaeology or
ethnography or anything like that but
I'm interested in the Greenland Norse
colonists and what they might have known
about the environment that they lived in
and how understanding about modern
climate oceanography meteorology might
inform that question so I'm interested
in asking these two questions what did
the Norse know about oceanography and
climate and then more specifically what
was the role of driftwood for the
Greenland Norse because they needed wood
for their activities and it was in short
supply so I'd like to talk about what
the Greenland Norse might have known
about these topics actually I'm only
going to really talk about the final
three tides sea is marine meteorology
non-tidal circulation climate
variability in driftwood so most of my
sources are historical so the sagas for
example or medieval books and some maps
so let me talk about the first three
very quickly there's lots of references
to the tide in the Greenland ice saga
for example or Eric's saga they've named
places like Stram fjord Australia
Stram Zi which means strong current and
they talk about the fortnightly be to
the tide in the Kings mirror which was
twelve mid twelve hundreds book and they
knew a lot about sea ice as well because
they had to operate in an environment
where sea ice was very common sea ice
obstructed commerce so this was a the
Norse Greenlanders lived in a colony
that was connected to Norway and then to
the rest of the world and in particular
to the Vatican
so there were regular trips between
Norway and Iceland and Greenland so sea
ice obstructed those commerce trips but
they also used the ice to hunt so in
winter for example in the hunting
grounds near Disko Bay they would hunt
on land fast ice so they were very aware
of the sea ice marine meteorology there
are lots of references to storms in the
sagas they were a hazard to seamanship
and there are some references to some
interesting optical phenomena associated
in the room marine meteorology too that
I don't want to talk about but I want to
focus mainly on 9 tidal circulation
climate variability in driftwood so this
is a medieval map of the area 1570 and
it shows the main places of interest
many of you know this I'm sure so
okay I can manage that a laser pointer
so you have the British Isles openly
Shetland Pharos Norway's on the right
Iceland and then on the left is
Greenland and there's this thing called
WITSEC which is a volcano thank you
which is a volcano which was or a large
prominent mountain across Denmark Strait
from Iceland
so here's Iceland Denmark Strait so this
was used for navigating they would sail
west from Iceland
until they could see the green and
mountains and then sail down the South
East Greenland coast
her jobs Ness is one of the eastern
settlements and then this is the
Labrador sea and Baffin Bay up here
Halil and Markland scrolling lands so
scrolling is the name for the natives
and then Finland of course which is
still debated exactly where Vinland was
it's sort of in the area of Newfoundland
Labrador on this map if we look at the
sequence of settlement in this area then
the timeline runs something like this so
British Isles Pharaoh's Shetland Orkney
and then Iceland 870 and then Eric the
red in 985 announces this this Greenland
and sets off with an expedition of many
ships from Iceland to colonize Southeast
Greenland and that occurred in two main
places one is the Eastern settlement
here and then a bit further up the coast
the Western settlement
biani her Jobson according to the sagas
saw the Canadian Shore around about at
that time when he was blown off-course
in a storm and then Eric the red Sun
Lafe eric stearn who was the figure in a
statue on the
slide is credited with discovering the
new world in the year 1000 and lived at
least for a few years somewhere in this
general area here so nobody knows where
Vinland is but there is at least
uncontroversial evidence of North
settlement on Newfoundland at Nassau
meadow which is right here which may
have been the place where they've
Ericsson lived and then there's another
guy called Thor think r7e who made
voyages to mark land and to Vinland at
around that time and most of the
documentary evidence from these sources
here the Greenland and the Eric saga the
Iceland saga and l'anima book wishes
book of the settlements which was an
Icelandic book and then the King's
mirror which is it's like an
encyclopedic description of knowledge of
their natural environment in the mid
13th century whitner's in the form of a
discussion between a father and his son
who's going out to explore this area so
if we look at the circulation then this
is what we see so we're talking about
the non-tidal circulation they knew a
lot about the ty but I'm thinking about
the low frequency general circulation of
the ocean and the surface circulation
and this is a modern map showing the
principal on tidal circulation in this
region and it's a map of what's called
the sea surface height so this is sea
level and it is a stream function for
the flow and what that means is you have
to imagine the way in which a bead on a
wire would slide along these contours so
the circulation is in the sense that it
would go round in a counterclockwise way
like this and the speed of motion on the
streamline is inversely proportional to
the gradient of the stream flow the
streamlines so where the streamlines are
tightly apparent the flow is rapid and
where they're wide apart the flow is
slow so we see the North Atlantic
Current which Fiamma mentioned heading
up towards spiritual and then into the
Nordic seas
and then some of it comes around and
recirculates and forms what's called the
East Greenland current here which is
narrow and rapid and against the
continental shelf break it turns around
Cape Farewell which is their forms the
West Greenland current some of that
recirculates in Davis Strait and comes
down the Labrador coast is called the
Labrador Current so of course the Norse
knew nothing about sea surface height
but they would have been observers of
sea surface temperature for example and
so this is the corresponding map for sea
surface temperature and you can see the
contours here twelve degrees C so this
is ten eight six degrees C so there's a
large fronts in temperature along the
east coast of Greenland that Fiamma was
referring to warm water and healing the
basin polar water coming down out
through Fram Strait in the Alps account
flow and then strong gradients at the
Shelf breaking on the Shelf itself and
simile for fear most talked about is
right here so human perception can
observe about a one degree sea change in
temperature so if you have two glasses
of water and one degree c apart you
stick your fingers in them you can tell
that there are different temperatures
smaller temperature differences that are
imperceptible but there are large
temperature differences here several
degrees four six eight ten degrees C so
I think it would be quite obvious to
people who routinely sailed around this
area that these temperature differences
were associated with their location even
if they were out of sight of land and
also with the ocean current itself so
the temperature is not quite a stream
function for the circulation but it
generally follows the stream lines that
I just showed you and the salinity tells
a similar story because the subtropical
water is salty and warm and the polar
water is cold and fresh and so these are
the ceilings you contours thirty five
thirty four point five and then some of
these get much smaller thirty three
thirty two point five so the Arctic
outflow through Fram Strait East
Greenland and through Baffin Bay and
then in the Labrador Current bring
cilenti's which are much lower than in
the central Arctic and about one
salinity unit on the scale on this scale
for practical salinity unit is at about
the limit of human perception if you
were to taste the water so we have
differences between the omega c and
shelf water here of maybe three or four
or more insulin C which would be quite
easily perceived if you tasted the water
so I think that probably the Greenland
north navigators were aware of that as
well and their rule of thumb would be
you sail east sorry you said west till
you see Greenland and then you stay in
the cold fresh water with the ice and
then so there's some other and it's Opel
evidence of to support this idea that
the Greenland Norse knew about the
circulation and it comes from some maps
so this is one map by a guy called Ellis
Magnus from the mid 16th century so he
was he was a diplomat who's a Swedish
diplomat to the Vatican and hero he drew
this map and then subsequently wrote an
encyclopaedia basically summary of
knowledge about people living in
northwest Europe and so here we see
Scandinavia so he's Denmark British
Isles Iceland is up here if we zoom in
to Iceland then we see there's Iceland
and here is Greenland so you see lots of
interesting things when you look
carefully at this for example you see
these big swirls and Eddie's which are
to the southeast of Greenland these have
been this is has been associated with
something which is called the Iceland
fara front which you can more or less
see here so there's a front in
temperature between Iceland Farrow and
then Scotland which is associated with
lots of Eddie's and instability in the
ocean circulation and this is
maybe maybe speculatively associated
with these worlds and Eddie's that you
see here to the southeast of Greenland
you can also see what's going on
sorry southeast of Iceland you can also
see what's going on here in Greenland
this is quite interesting and in the
encyclopedia the Ellis Magnus wrote a
couple of decades later there are wood
cuts associated with each chapter and
this is one of those wood cuts which is
in an elaboration of what is shown here
so you see people on the shore and then
in the ocean you see driftwood and
broken ships so you can see driftwood
here and people here are living in some
sort of shack like structures it's a
little unclear if these are natives or
if these are colonists some people have
said that these whalebone and there is
evidence that the north's used whale
bones in building construction and but
also that the Thule natives used whale
bones in building construction too so
the thing that Olaus Magnus associated
with when he thought about Greenland was
driftwood and these shipwrecks floating
in the water
now the driftwood has a non-local origin
so it's come from the Arctic in fact
principally it's come from Siberia and
so this implicitly to my mind is
evidence that the Greenlanders and our
last Magnus was aware of the non-tidal
circulation in other words the driftwood
had been brought from elsewhere to
Greenland and that driftwood was an
important commodity for the green
industry sure we'll talk about in a
little while okay so now I want to
switch gears and talk a little about
climate variability and initially I'm
going to talk about inter-annual climate
variability maybe over a few decades and
mainly about the North Atlantic
Oscillation which we've heard something
about
already and this is one of my this is
like the poster child picture for the
North Atlantic Oscillation
it shows the cam River in Cambridge in
the winter of nineteen
three my father took this picture so
this is Newton's mathematical bridge and
most people experience the cam in a punt
in May and they don't think of it as
being frozen but my dad told me that
people would skate to lectures in the
winter of 1963 because it was frozen for
so long and so hard and 1963 was a
particularly extreme phase of the North
Atlantic Oscillation it was a negative
phase and this diagram shows some of the
phenomena associated with the North
Atlantic Oscillation which we've already
heard is to do primarily with a change
in the pressure between the
high-pressure system over here in the
subtropical eastern Atlantic over the
Azores and the low-pressure system over
here in the sub polar and sit near
Iceland so in the negative phase the
storm track tends to be depressed
towards the south and a bit weaker fewer
storms and then northwest Europe tends
to be dry and cold 1963 the camera's
frozen it is also associated with
relatively warm conditions in the
Labrador sea Baffin Bay and West
Greenland and which will become relevant
in a little while you tend to have high
sea-level pressure in the central Arctic
as well and in the Beaufort gyre so the
positive phase is more or less the
opposite and now there's a big pressure
difference between there's always high
in the Iceland low an intense storm
track which tends to go towards
northwest Europe preferentially and for
that reason it is warmer and wetter in
that part of the world low sea level
pressure over the central Arctic and
relatively cold in Atlantic Canada in
Baffin Bay and in South West Greenland
so here's a time series of the North
Atlantic Oscillation as an index now
the last 110 years so 1963 is here
it oscillates up and down with this kind
of variability and when the index is
negative you have mild winters in South
West Greenland and when it is positive
you have hard cold long winters and if
you look at climate data from a
particular location in southwest England
for example narsarsuaq which is in the
Eastern settlement then you can see the
impacts of the North Atlantic
Oscillation on temperature so this
diagram shows that December January
February March average temperature over
the last 60 or 70 years in that location
going up and down so this is wintertime
temperature and the NAO index which I
just showed you is down here so you can
see when the NAO index is positive you
tend to have hard winters and it can be
hard by several degrees colder than
average okay so this is the average
climate record for narsarsuaq over this
period 1961 to 1990 so the average
temperature for DJ FM is about minus six
degrees something like that but you can
have winters where the four month
average temperature can be several
degrees colder than that associated with
one of the so I think that the Greenland
Norse would have been sensitive to this
because it would have made the growing
season shorter the melt would have taken
would have been delayed they'd have been
had more heavy reliance on materials to
burn and to livestock would have been
stressed more in hard winters like these
so now let's talk about Centennial
variability so this is my poster child
picture for the Little Ice Age so this
is a this guy was a Dutch painter
hunters in the snow painted in 1565 and
it shows hunters returning from a hunt
which has been unsuccessful
and you can see people skate
on the frozen ponds and the water wheel
here is frozen so this has been
associated with what people call the
Little Ice Age so if we look at a
temperature time series over the past
2,000 years then you get this kind of
pattern it's a reconstruction relative
to the average over the last 40 or 50
years 1961 to 1990 so zero is that
average so the Little Ice Age is this
dip in the middle ages and you can see
the timeline for the various things that
we've been talking about so thousand
when the new world was discovered it was
during the Medieval Warm Period and then
in the late 1400s which is when last
word was received from the green and
Norse by the Vatican they were entering
the Little Ice Age okay so nobody knows
exactly what happens to green the Norse
but by the middle of 1400 say appear to
have died out or have moved on and for
several decades there was no word from
them but their vote the magnitude of
this variability on this scale in
centigrade here is much smaller than the
variability that you get with the nao so
this scale here is about ten times
smaller than the scale here okay so
although the Little Ice Age and Medieval
Warm Period are legitimate phenomena
you're talking about a difference in
temperature of maybe half a degree and
that is very small compared to the
difference in temperature from one
winter to the next associated with a
North Lance cross alation so my feeling
is that the the Little Ice Age is
probably not a very important factor in
extra stress on the green and Norse
explaining why they they disappeared in
the Middle Ages and I think that the
North Atlantic Oscillation would have
been a much more important stressor okay
so now let me talk a bit about driftwood
and then finish so I showed you this
picture and I said I think this is
evidence that the green in Norse were
knowledgeable of the surface circulation
least a boundary circulation in the
North Atlantic and that they exploited
her in navigating in this area operating
for 500 years but this picture also
points to the importance of driftwood
driftwood as commodity for their
existence so I want to talk a little
about that their technology was based on
wood so this is the main piece of
technology the nor the boat of course
it's wooden they can't operate their
lifestyle without wood to build and
repair boats like this it's also very
important for housing in Greenland so
this is a picture from car Katoch in
South West Greenland and it shows a
traditional turf and stone building so
this is the walls of this are made of
stone and turf there is not much wood in
it but there is some wood in it for
example you can't really have a roof on
a building like this without wood you
need long strong members to support the
roof whereas your existence is pretty
primitive and the Greenlanders would
have used wood both for their ships and
for buildings so the sources of wood for
the green and northwest follows Markland
so this is the Labrador coast it's
called mark mark land means wooded Shore
so today wood sorry forests go to about
58 degrees north in Labrador that's at
about the 10 degrees C isotherm which is
a large part of the Labrador sure and
there are lots of sources of evidence
that show that the Green and Norse went
from the eastern settlement to the
Western settlement crossed Davis Strait
to mark land to collect wood and then
returned but that probably died out at
some point during the 1300 so the
Western settlement which was the staging
post for that for those expeditions
disappeared at some point in the mid or
late 1300s so although there was a ready
source of wood from Labrador at least
late in the history of the
it became less important wood was
imported as well from Norway so in the
Kings mirror for example it says that
all of the wood which is used in
buildings has to be imported from Norway
that also that source of wood also
declined presumably in the end stages of
the colony in the 1300s and the 1400s
because they were just fewer and fewer
voyages and contact was lost native wood
is another candidate source but there's
very little native wood in Greenland so
there's some scrub willow that lives
naturally in Greenland there's some
birch but it doesn't grow very high
there no coniferous trees in Greenland
there have been some experiments to try
and bring forestry to grow and learn and
so for example in the 1890s there was
some pine Scots pine planted up
opposites Erik the Reds farm in
brattahlid some of those trees survived
to today but they're only 5 metres tall
so in 130 years they grew 5 metres
there's no evidence that I'm aware of
that the Greenland Norse deliberately
tried to grow forests but even if they
had they would have been growing so
slowly that it wouldn't have been a
sustainable option to support their
housing and their shipbuilding and so
the final source is driftwood and so I
think as time went by towards the end of
the colony driftwood became a more and
more important source of wood so
driftwood reaches the beaches of
Greenland from as I said from the Arctic
driftwood is carried by the ice so a
tree that falls into the into a river
and then flows out into the Arctic will
float for around about a year before it
sinks
unless it's caught in ice and if it's
caught in ice and it can look it can
survive for as long as the ice is still
buoyant so almost all of the wood wishes
are which arrives from which arrives at
Greenland beaches has been carried by
ice and it can survive on beaches inger
in for a long period so that if you date
the wood on the green
beaches than its thousands of years old
the oldest specimens maybe even 10,000
years there's no evidence that the
native the Inuit used
driftwood so presumably when the north's
arrived there was a more or less
pristine supply of driftwood on the
beaches there is lots of evidence that
the grinders did use driftwood for
various purposes but I think probably it
became harder and harder to collect and
it was a diminishing resource that
essentially they exhausted but I want to
close by talking a little bit more about
the way in which the Oceanography and
the ice floe in the Arctic would have
affected the supply of driftwood so this
is a couple of figures showing the winds
and the surface flow in the Arctic and
they're in two particular phases summer
of 1989 winter of 2007
they'll correspond more or less to
different phases of the NAO okay so the
one on the left is the positive nao and
the one on the right is the negative
area this is not quite true okay these
two periods were selected because they
tend to show characteristically
different circulation patterns in the
Arctic rather than being extreme phases
of the NAO however it is more or less
true that they map onto positive nao
phase and their negative area phase like
that
so in color you see sea level pressure
and sea level pressure is a stream
function for the Jewish prophet flow the
wind at the surface of the ocean so like
the bead on the wire idea the
atmospheric winds are blowing around
these contours this big red blob for
example or along this gradient between
the blue low sea level pressure and the
red high sea level pressure to its side
and then these white streak lines are
the drift of ice so this is this is data
from satellite observations of ice
drifts over the last 40 years or so and
the trajectories I think they last
of months so what we did was we we
computed the trajectories of ice for
winter 2007 as if that applied for 12
months and then plotted the tracks and
you can see what we saw earlier that in
this phase here winter 2007 there is a
very strong anticyclonic circulation it
here in the Beaufort Sea it's called the
Beaufort gyre and then a strong trans
polar drift from Siberia across the pole
towards Fram Strait and then a large
outflow through Fram Strait so this is
ice flowing out down south past East
Greenland and it's much weaker both the
Beaufort gyre and the trans polar drift
in this other phase and the outflow
through Fram Strait is much weaker so
now let's think about driftwood again so
there's two principal sources there's
the Siberian coast which is primarily
larch and then the North American coast
which is primarily the Mackenzie River
and spruce and so you can if you look at
the provenance of if you look at the
species of wood in an artifact from
Greenland for example you can tell where
it's come from and so when the transport
of drift is strong you're going to be
bringing Siberian driftwood across
through Fram Strait when the transfer of
drift is weak then you have a low
driftwood flux so at times of negative
nao I think there would be high
driftwood flux coming through Fram
Strait at times of positive anyhow it
would be low and as I said earlier the
high and low phases of they know quart
nao corresponds to hard or mild winters
and south screening so when it was
positive with a low driftwood flux it
would be a hard winter
ok colder than average that means there
would have been a lot of local freezing
in the fields so there's a lot of sea
ice which is formed locally which lasts
for a long time and for both of these
reasons high local freezing and low
supply of driftwood this would be a time
of almost no resupply of driftwood and
contrast that with this phase here a
mild winter low local freezing so
there's less sea ice in the fields lots
of driftwood offshore this would have
been a time
when there would have been a high supply
of driftwood so this is a double whammy
for the Greenland Norse because not only
do they have when it's a positive nao
not only do they have to survive a very
hard winter they also have to have
survived low driftwood supply and it
would have been the converse for the
other phase of the nao so here my
conclusions well actually these are
speculations
I don't really claim to know these facts
for sure I think the green in Norse knew
about and exploited a surface boundary
current circulation at North in the
Northwest Atlantic I think their inter
annual climate variability in
particularly nao was more stressful than
Centennial variability and I think that
this interaction between the driftwood
supply and the nao and then the severity
that winces would have been a boom or
bust cycle especially at the end of the
Greenland colonies when they were then
run out of all of their other sources of
wood okay that's it thank you